hey I'm rocket Riley and I make videos
about movies and sometimes TV shows
[Music]
this is rocket Riley well this channel
centers on your favorite fandoms whether
it be Star Wars Game of Thrones Marvel
or whatever else is trending that means
things like did I leave the stove on or
it's like a pirate
or even I don't like sand
this channel is for you if you like to
talk about popular movies or nerdy TV
shows and it's especially for you if
you're watching this video I don't like
unnecessarily long or clickbaity videos
so my goal is to get straight to the
point and keep you up to date on
everything happening in the nerd world
and hopefully entertain you along the
way the real question is this
absolutely not if you're not already
subscribed then you're missing out on
things like trailer breakdowns video
essays movie reviews and news and
updates about upcoming movies and TV
shows
I thought it was about time that I got
on camera and told you all what rocket
Riley is all about and since you made it
this far it's about time for you to hit
the Subscribe button go ahead oh wait
okay I think we're done